hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week where I will flawlessly deliver
an amazing amazing slice of value to you
today this week we're talking about cmmc
control
ir.l2-3.6.2 honestly we're really
talking about Grumpier Old Men in
between takes but for right now we'll
talk about we'll talk about this control
uh track document and Report incidents
to designated officials and or
authorities both internal and external
to the organization
[Music]
thank you so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
this cmmc dfars and nist SP 800171
compliance stuff or just my bad jokes on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it why
is this a requirement why oh why is this
a requirement I've been asking like for
years right because remember this
standard is all about protecting control
and classified information which is not
just any old kind of information as a
result the government actually mandates
that if you had an incident and cuis
compromised you must have in your
standard operating procedures somewhere
to call the proper authorities in other
words you don't cover it up okay
you know you don't get ransomware on a
network with defense information and
they go I'm gonna just wipe everything
and start over restore from it no you've
got to alert the authorities if there is
an issue you've got to have the needed
mechanisms like a medium security
assessment for defense industrial based
cyber incident reporting uh you've got
to have your ducks in a row and ready to
go when it comes to alerting authorities
to come give you a hand investigate the
situation and make sure whoever those
attackers are can be hunted down to the
extent possible and that the authorities
are aware of what has happened for the
purposes of national security so let's
see what the assessors are looking for
on this one a lot apparently that's a
lot more than I anticipated in terms of
the number of assessment points
um I should probably like maybe look
over my scripts before I read them but
that's way too much effort like yeah
we're low budget here at on-call uh all
right first one determine if incidents
are tracked Implement see instant
response policy and instant response
form all instance are tracked and
documented within the it ticketing
system using the incident response form
so again what you're really going to be
doing here is you're going to be
demonstrating how you're tracking
incense and of course you guys know uh
if you're even a small shop you should
be using a ticketing system if you're
like a one to five person crew it's
probably just email but somehow you've
got to be able to demonstrate how these
incidents are tracked
next one determine if incidents are
documented okay yes you have to document
things uh again uh we would say C
instant response policy incident
response form right the form or if it's
digital you know whatever digital form
you're filling out to document how the
incident happened all incidents are
tracked and documented within the it
ticketing system is a very common
response to this assessment Point uh
determinive authorities to whom
incidents are to be reported are
identified implemented CNC response
policy and incident response form again
uh determine if organizational officials
to whom incidents are to be reported are
identified so I would say this is a key
thing that maybe a lot of I.T
departments don't really sort of take
into account you should have an
escalation path and it should be
documented and if you don't have that
you're in trouble okay and there should
be some point to where an issue is
escalated all the way to the top it
should be formalized and it should be in
writing uh determine if identified
authorities are notified of incidents
yes you really should have in your plan
this is the point in time when it's bad
enough call the cops call the FBI call
the military whatever it may be those
things need to be in your plan determine
if identified organizational officials
are notified of incidents so again we're
out we're at first we were talking about
determine if organizational officials
Tim incense are to be reported on or
identified so are they in the plan are
they identified they determine if
identified if organizational officials
are notified of incidents so you're
going to probably have to find some
evidence that they were you know talked
to or notified in some official way when
a severe enough issue has occurred
now if you
have your head on
backwards after listening to what it
takes to solve that one control the good
news is here at on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this defars nist itar and CMC
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like I see though on a sunny day
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that is
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you and your boss will love
you when you're like hey man sales team
we can go tell everybody that we're
compliant now hooray let's go call of
our past clients we haven't heard from
in two years and let them know that
we're awesome and super secure to work
with that's a great touch point and we
teach stuff like that because at the end
of the day it's one thing to be
compliant keep the business you have but
it's a whole other thing to be able to
actually grow with this stuff we can
teach you how if you're looking for more
of that cool stuff our compliance
experts are always on call for you okay
visit cmfcc complianceecrets.com or
check out the bio below for links to get
help right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerves roll it out until the
next compliance it my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]
anyway